tu as prévu quoi pour les vacances
partir en vacances
[Applaudissements]
les mecs je peux vous dire sans bien le
connaître que cette personne est un peu
bouffer des cubes pendant les vacances
je me suis pris la table dans le dos
de travail des meufs
donc des gens que je connais parce que
forcément
appelle-moi
[Applaudissements]
respect le mec qui arrive à faire passer
à sa meuf je pars en Crète avec des
potes pour aller voir des paysages
parents
[Rires]
déjà je te félicite merci
je connais ce que je connais bien donc
je vais leur faire visiter quoi
à la confiance
je lui ai proposé
quel bonheur non mais c'est vrai ni de
cette de ce voyage en Crète par contre
vous n'avez pas appelé mais non tu
parles pas ailleurs
[Rires]
un peu comme l'image de paddle mais non
non
c'est sûr et certain ta meuf elle annule
ce voyage
donc toi tu es content
une semaine en vacances
une personne tu la connais à 9h du matin
à 16h tu as l'impression d'être avec
elle depuis 4 ans moi je me rappelle
j'étais au club frère je connais la meuf
à l'aquagym à 9h à 9h15 on était au tir
à l'arc sur la tête de ma mère on était
comme ça l'arc dans les mains comme ça
tous les deux arc dans l'arc tu vois on
allait on doit et qu'on ait plus quittés
de toute la vie sans déconner on arrive
comme asse aux écoles le soir on
réflectoire commence
chéri tu veux des bacalao il y a
toujours des trucs des beignets de morue
tu vois non tu vas chercher une assiette
pour ta meuf et tout maintenant la meuf
tu la connais depuis 10h sans déconner
tu as l'impression que c'est parti tu
appelles ta mère on va m'en essayer j'ai
marié avec qui jean-christiane euh bah
je viens de la connaître là c'est le
prof de quoi gym euh non le sang donc là
une semaine dans la même maison que tu
sais toi as-tu pour but pendant ces
vacances de Ken non parce qu'on y va
entre collègues de travail donc entre
collègues tu vas te [__] de ma gueule
encore combien d'années
[Applaudissements]
par contre si vous partez non plus